joining us now is dr tom frieden the
former director of the cdc he's now
president and ceo of resolve to save
lives an initiative working to protect
people from cardiovascular disease and
prevent epidemics dr frieden thank you
so much for being with us we appreciate
it you know we just heard from meg i
think this is so confusing for parents
you hear that hospitalizations are up
you hear the new cdc guidance if you
have little kids you're wondering what
to do with child care what advice do you
have
well first and foremost get vaccinated
and if it's time get boosted we're going
to be talking about whether you're up to
date with your code vaccinations and as
we learn more what that means may change
with time but vaccination is by far the
most important thing that we need to do
also what your correspondent just
covered is very important we all need to
work together to keep kids in school and
learning and we can do that by
vaccinating boosting and masking up
so dr freda you'll agree that this is
sort of confusing for a lot of people
because the cdc is now saying americans
who test positive for covid can stop
isolating after five days uh if they no
longer have symptoms but they should
still wear a mask what do you think
prompted this move because i suspect
that there will be a lot of people who
will see this guidance and wonder what
this really means and what this has
meant over the course of the entire
pandemic
here's the bottom line the virus is
adapting omicron is different very
different from prior strains and we need
to adapt too so appropriately the cdc is
adapting their guidance for the current
situation they're doing so in real time
we wish we knew more we wish we knew how
severe omicron is going to be but we
won't know that for a few weeks we wish
we were able to protect kids under age
five but currently we don't have a
vaccine for them that's why it's so
important that everyone five and over
get vaccinated and boosted to protect
all of us remember over 50 american kids
have been killed by coed so far and
thousands have suffered from the
inflammatory condition that rarely
follows it but can be quite severe and
life-threatening we all need to work
together and if we do that we can
prevent kovid from dominating our lives
in 2022.
dr fredon you mentioned uh being boosted
now the cdc says individuals that have
received their booster shot should not
need um
shouldn't uh need to quarantine so if
that is the case um then them wearing a
mask for 10 days around individuals is
that enough time or do they need to wear
a mask after that
10 days is a conservative amount and
frankly anytime you're indoors with a
lot of other people mask up it protects
you and it protects others around you
especially where omicron is spreading a
lot and especially if people there or
people they have contact with are older
or have weakened immune systems masks
are a very small price to pay to keep
our economy moving keep our schools
learning in person and save lives
i think there's a lot of questions about
testing too i know a lot of people who
got their positive tests they now hear
these new guidelines
part of the guidelines is not to test
negative out of this one expert calls
that reckless should a negative test be
part of this five-day new rule or what
do you think about this the cdc does say
that if you've been exposed best
practice would be to test it five days
before leaving quarantine but you know
cdc makes guidance and recommendations
in the real world not the world that we
wish existed and right now there aren't
enough tests and furthermore the data
suggests that with omicron you're most
infectious a day or two before you get
sick and for the first day or two after
you've gotten sick so it's a reasonable
approach to keep our economy moving save
lives and be practical in a way that we
can make sure that covid doesn't
dominate our lives and the lives of
people around us through 2022.
that is certainly the wish dr frieden
thank you so much for the clarity as
always we appreciate you